[Musique]
c'est le restaurant dont tout le monde
parle ici à coanière et pour cause
difficile de passer à côté avec sa
deventure rose bonbon le restaurant
bomba carton sur les réseaux sociaux je
vous propose qu'on aille découvrir le
[Musique]
concept
bonjour bienvenue à bomba bienvenue dans
notre univers et en effet en poussant
les portes du concept on découvre un
univers à part entière au style vintage
et old school et comme à l'extérieur ici
le rose régneant maître jusque dans les
moindres détails de quoi attirer l'œil
et l'estomac des clients et je ne suis
pas la seule à avoir voulu découvrir le
concept ici on trouve de nombreux
habitués mais aussi des clients venus
découvrir pour la première fois on est
déjà venue c'est la troisème fois et
qu'est-ce qui vous a attiré qu'est-ce
qui vous plaît ici ben déjà la
nourriture c'est vrai que c'est pas la
street food habituelle c'est beaucoup
plus élaboré et bah l'environnement il
est sympa très girly est super belle la
déco le rose et tout le fait qu'il y a
des vêtements aussi là-bas franchement
c'est sympa il y a pas ça à côté enfin
c'est la première fois qu'il y a ça dans
notre secteur et euh bah c'est sympa
depuis son ouverture en février 2023
l'établissement ne désemple pas une
centaine de couverts sont servis chaque
jour Medy vous êtes le gérant du concept
bomba est-ce que pouvez nous présenter
un petit peu cet établissement bon bah
c'est un concept comme je disais
lifestyle c'est vraiment en mode de
vie on fait de la Food mode et culture
c'est vraiment nos trois piliers la fot
parce que c'est notre savoir-faire la
mode c'est venue naturellement parce que
c'est ce qu'on kiffe C food un peu
retravailler mixer à d'autres univers la
culture parce que c'est vraiment ce qui
nous a construit à première vue géré on
pense que c'est que pour les jeunes on
voit du rose la modernité de la musique
et cetera mais quand on rentre vraiment
en immersion dans ce concept là en fait
c'est fait pour tout le monde alors la
musique ça attire la nourriture ça
attire mais ce qui attire aussi ici
c'est le restaurant la couleur le rose
partout et cette décoration incroyable
comment comment vous avez réfléchi ça
c'est venu très simplement le rose
pourquoi parce que le rose c'est une
couleur qui casse les côtes euh de par
son histoire au rose moi quand j'étais
petit personne mettait du rose et un
garçon qui met du rose on se disait
c'est pas possible alors qu'aujourd'hui
vraiment le rose c'est c'est un peu
notre histoire c'est dire bah on vient
on casse les codes et tout le monde nous
prend quoi voilà l'univers qu'on
retrouve ici c'est un univers que vous
avez créé avec vos frères c'est une
histoire familiale aussi c'est une
fierté ouais bien sûr c'est une fierté
tout le monde dans ma famille il
participe ce concept là c'est notre
histoire et tout le monde il met du sien
mes frères voilà ils mettent leurs
petits ajouts leur kiff et moi aussi et
du coup ça fait vraiment une histoire
familiale de a Z quoi ce concept bon ben
alors on va aller tester ça merci on y
va bon appétit est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire un petit peu là ce que vous
nous avez préparé ouais je vous ai mis
des choses sympas des petites wings
Pepper poivre et citron des petites
sauces homemade un burger à la truffe
avec du comté ça c'est génial c'est un
concentré de tout ce qu'on peut trouver
ici finalement exactement là vraiment
j'ai mis mes petits préférés quand même
c'est parti pour la dégustation ici les
recettes ont été pensées pendant
plusieurs mois et travailler en
collaboration avec de grands chefs parmi
les incontournables de bomba ce burger à
la truff ces frites de patates douces ou
encore ces tenders de poulet dont
raffolent les clients ici tous les
produits sont faits maison même ces Cook
conçu dans la pâtisserie du restaurant
pour un repas compte entre 10 et 13 €.
une fois le repas terminé vous pouvez
faire des achats dans l'espace mode et
culture du restaurant alors ici ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'on met en valeur des
marques des petites marques de jeunes
créateurs qui me plaisent beaucoup et
qui plaisent aussi à notre clientèle on
a on retrouve plein de petites marques
qui vous s'inscrit toujours un peu dans
notre da on collectionne aussi des
petites pièces comme cette veste là qui
est assez sympa cette veste là c'est une
veste légendaire mais fait qu'un fr
c'est quelque chose qui nous AB tout
reste un petit peu dans le même esprit
on retrouve quand même pas mal de Ros
là-dedans ça c'est sûr c'est évident et
c'est et c'est logique hein que ce soit
bien notre marque les cagoules Ros et
via aussi les marques not créateur qui
jouent le
jeu il est déjà 14h30 et c'est la fin du
service vous le voyez derrière moi le
restaurant c'est bien vidé alors si vous
aussi vous voulez découvrir le bomba
concept rendez-vous à coanière et c'est
ouvert tous les jours du lundi au
dimanche